I would like to make a statement
about the inquiry into the horrendous
attack on Manchester Arena on the 22nd
of May 2017.
language speaker I work closely with MI5
and asked its activities necessarily
discrete the whole country should be
profoundly grateful for the patriotism
and courage of its staff they work
indophatically every day to keep the
British people safe
since the start of 2017 MI5 and the
police have disrupted 37 late stage
attack
the Mad object
dismiss them as suicide bomber murdered
22 people and injured over a thousand as
well as inflicting incalculable
psychological damage and misery
I know that the whole house will join me
in expressing our profound sorrow and
extending our heartfelt condolences to
everyone affected by this barbaric act
they were supposed to have a brilliant
time and come home safely
what should have been a simple pleasure
turned into a hellish nightmare
it's vital that we understand what
happened and what lessons we need to
learn
because we must do everything possible
to prevent a repeat of this outrage
volume 3 of the inquiry was published
last Thursday I want to thank Sir John
Saunders and his team who spent more
than three years on it
Sir John finds
that there was a failure by the security
service to act swiftly enough and
problems with the sharing of information
between the security service and
counter-terrorism policing
following the publication of the report
the director general of MI5 and the head
of counter-terrorism policing offered
their profound apologies
for not preventing the attack
Sir John does not blame any of the
educational establishments that the
bomber attended for failing to identify
that he was a risk but he does find that
more needs to be done to ensure that
education providers share relevant
information about students
so John concludes that the bomber should
have been subject to prevent referral at
some point in 2015 or 2016 adding
however it is very hard to say what
would have happened if he had been
approached under prevent or the Channel
program
the police investigation to the attack
operation mantlein is praised
although Sir John cannot conclude
whether the attack that the attack would
have been prevented he finds that there
was a significant missed opportunity to
take further investigative action that
he judges might have led to information
which could have prevented it
while this is welcome and the home
office will work at PACE with both
organizations to act on the Chairman's
recommendations we must not lose sight
of the fact that responsibility for the
attack lies with the bomber and his
brother
so these conclusions require careful
consideration now in Deputy speaker
since 2017 the government has made a
number of changes to how we deal with
and seek to prevent terrorist attacks
we have given law enforcement and
intelligence agencies improved Powers we
have strengthened the controls around
access to explosives precursors
we've strengthened the management of
terrorist and terrorist risk offenders
in prison and on license
We've Ended the automatic early release
of terrorist defenders in England Wales
and Scotland
and we've ensured that the sentences
served by terrorists reflect the
severity of their offending
and we've strengthened the tools for
monitoring dangerous people in the
community
we've invested heavily in
counterterrorism unveiling a new
counter-terrorism operations center in
2021 that brings together Partners from
counter-terrorism policing the
intelligence agencies the criminal
justice system and other government
agencies
this will allow minute-by-minute
collaboration between teams and the
police and the MI5 and MI5
last year's integration of special
Branch into the national CT policing
network will improve our response to the
full range of National Security threats
boost skills and ensure better
communication between agencies and a
more consistent and effective national
response
[Applause]
work is currently underway to develop a
new Faith security training scheme to
raise security awareness amongst Faith
communities and help them to mitigate
threats we continue to engage with faith
organizations and Security Experts to
develop this scheme
in April my writing will found the
member for Whitton
announced the continuation of the Jewish
Community protective security grant for
2022 in May new funding was allocated to
provide protective security at mosques
and Muslim faith schools
in response to any terrorist attack
affecting British Nationals in the UK or
overseas the home officers victims of
terrorism unit Works to ensure the right
support is available to them the unit is
conducting an internal review to
strengthen their work
I am overseeing a comprehensive review
of the contest strategy to combat
terrorism
this follows on from the Independent
review of prevent led by William
shawcross which assessed the program's
Effectiveness in stopping people from
becoming terrorists or supporting
terrorism
and as the independent review made clear
prevent requires major reform and I've
accepted all of the reviews
recommendations
it has underestimated the threat of
islamist extremism which Remains by far
the biggest that we face too often it
has minimized the role of ideology and
terrorism prevent will focus on security
not on political correctness and its
first objective will be to tackle the
ideological causes of terrorism
the government has also developed a
comprehensive system of support for the
owners and operators of public places
across the UK
this includes access to research driven
expertise through products delivered by
the National counter-terrorism Security
office and the center for protection of
national infrastructure
but we must go further Madam Deputy
speaker Martin's law formerly known as
the protect Duty will introduce
proportionate new security requirements
for certain public premises throughout
the UK
they will be better prepared ready to
respond and their staff will know what
to do in the event of a terrorist attack
Martin's law will clarify who is
responsible for security activity at the
premises in scope increasing
accountability
we are also considering how a full
inspection function will oversee
compliance to provide appropriate advice
and where necessary to sanction
Martin hett was one of those killed in
Manchester
I'm enormously grateful to his mother
Fegan Murray and the Martin laws
campaign team as well as to survivors
Against Terror and all security Partners
businesses Charities local authorities
and victims group
that have informed our work
I've always been humbled when I've met
them and heard about their experiences
the doctrines that underpin how the
Emergency Services respond to incidents
have improved since the attack
so Madam Deputy speaker I want to close
by once again recognizing the anguish
and courage
of the loved ones of those who were
killed or hurt on that Dreadful night
that United the country in sorrow and in
disgust
we will continue to work Non-Stop
prevent further such tragedies being
visited upon others and I commend this
statement to the house